dans cet hypermarché tout est prêt pour
la distribution de masques dès lundi
mais si les stocks sont là inutile de se
précipiter à l'ouverture ils ne seront
délivrées ici que sous certaines
conditions
tous nos clients que sont porteurs d'une
carte de fidélité ont reçu un mail dans
ce mail lorette indiqué un code pour
venir retirer
un jour donné leur masque ce sont des
boîtes de 50 masques des masques
chirurgicaux les mêmes que ceux que
pierre-olivier vario distribuer au
compte gouttes dans son officine et
seulement aux professionnels de santé
on a dit non à plein de patients qu'elle
avait besoin qui partait en chimio
qu'était qu'ovide positif qui devait
protéger leur famille on a dit non on
n'a pas le droit
et aujourd'hui on apprend avec stupeur
que la grande distribution en a 400
millions à disposition des français ils
viennent d'où ces masques là c'est
inadmissible les bureaux de tabac
pourront eux aussi proposer des masques
réutilisables à la vente mais beaucoup
ne seront pas livrés à temps ce
buraliste par exemple sait déjà qu'il ne
recevra pas sa commande à vomi mais
problème c'est que il ya vingt-quatre
mille buralistes 24 min et on commande
une certaine quantité
le fournisseur se poursuivre d'ici
quelques jours le grand public devrait
pouvoir choisir où se fournir en masque
mais ce qui inquiète l'ufc que choisir
c'est le budget que leur achat va
représenter même en optant pour les
moins chers on ne peut pas rendre
quelque chose obligatoire dans l'intérêt
général et que ce soit payant surtout
payant dans les conditions où on a des
prix on les a annoncé lui même si c'est
plafonné à 95 centimes usage unique
quand vous avez une famille avec deux ou
trois enfants on est à plus de 200 euros
240 euros par mois les masques
réutilisables que prévoit aussi de
proposer prochainement la grande
distribution devrait revenir deux fois
moins cher devrait puisque pour
l'instant les prix de ces types de
masques sont libres